many of us are fortunate to have
partners that we love spending a lot of
time with it's also good to miss that
person every once in a while now that
might be an hour for some people apart
of no communication it might be a week
everyone varies on this on the spectrum
but the idea of missing someone is that
positive anticipation that kind of pain
right it's a motivational state and then
when you see them it's all the richer so
you can
imagine that these dopamine circuits can
be used to more successfully navigate a
number of different things and you know
a lot of couples completely quash the
excitement and the pleasure of being
together not just physical pleasure but
just pleasure of being together because
they just
spend too much damn time familiarity or
they're texting that all the time right
or they're you know and this whole thing
around texting has become a really
interesting test of dopamine expectation
there's this thing called dopamine
reward prediction error if you think the
reward is coming and it doesn't you drop
below baseline levels of dopamine that's
why you should never tell someone that
this restaurant is going to be the best
restaurant you've ever been to in your
life exactly i made the mistake of
telling my girlfriend on the way here i
want her to read this book i'm like this
is an amazing book you should read her
and i caught myself and i thought damn
it i'm actually detracting from how
good she's going to experience the book
tell her it was terrible oh yeah it's
really good though this is the problem
it's hard to do so um i think the key is
to uh
to leverage dopamine reward prediction
error in the best way it's the surprise
that you know if you take kids you're
driving home from school and suddenly
you pull into the ice cream shop
they're going to be so ecstatic but if
you tell them you're going to go the ice
cream shop and it's closed
huge drop below baseline does that mean
if you tell them that you're going to
the ice cream shop and it's open that's
less than not telling them that you're
going to the ice cream shop and it's
surprised correct it's it's they
literally tear out into maxim surprise
is the maximum dopamine release then
successful completion of the missions
as it were is the next and then
unsuccessful is there not an argument to
be made that you would be able to uh
drag out the amount of time that
dopamine is released for because of the
anticipation
yeah so well and people do this in
relationship quite a lot right
anticipation is the kind of ultimate
fuel of the courting dance right i mean
this is also but one has to be very
careful because whether or not it's from
the male side or the female side or
whatever variation thereof
there's a you only get so many reward
prediction errors before people start to
predict or associate
low dopamine with somebody or some
experience in other words if you you
know i'll use an example uh not for my
own life but if you say you know we're
going to costa rica on vacation and then
you say listen i have to work they might
understand but that's a letdown it's a
dopamine reward prediction error in the
direction of lower dopamine they might
recover from it they might not but most
people recover from it if you do that
two or three times what ends up
happening you can
model this beautifully and they've seen
this experimentally in animals and
humans then you say okay we're really
going to costa rica this time and you
think well the surprise is going to be
that you actually go the amount of
dopamine that's released for positive
for successful completion of the initial
goal is far lower than it ever would
have been so you can only cry wolf's i
suppose that's not the right way to put
it you can only
um create positive anticipation so many
times and then create a letdown before
completion that the pro delivery of the
promise has very little impact and so
you have to be very careful with one's
words better to say nothing
than to let somebody down
for sure in the context of human
relationship and you know this plays out
in some um less perhaps uh amusing ways
where you know you look at people who
are successful in life and you always
hear success build success and it's
absolutely true like when students come
to my lab and they do a phd thesis it's
very important for me to get them onto a
research track quickly that they're
going to experience some success because
if they spend
four years and then it fails that's
devastating and then they have to start
over again same thing with kids i mean
getting
some success early on
even if it's low bar success really does
build up one's positive anticipation
and ability to perform well in the
future because dopamine gives energy
remembers the precursor to adrenaline
and the sense that the world is
predictable
now this can go a wrong way too and i
see this a lot with the idea that
everyone gets a blue ribbon this is
terrible too because
if everyone is rewarded every child is
rewarded regardless of how well they
performed if they're all rewarded to the
same level you actually flatten the
dopamine curve and so in that sense yes
everyone might feel
you know celebrated but you actually are
lowering motivation for
the given activity this has a whole
landscape of research in back of it
related to intrinsic versus extrinsic
reward the strongest motivation is
always going to be intrinsic motivation
if you reward kids or adults for
something too many times even if they
like that activity the
propensity to do that activity will be
reduced but if you reward without effort
or without success
that is devastating for a nervous system
in fact i've gone on record and i'll say
it again and again and again which is
that
dopamine
that
arrives without prior effort
destroys people this is
this is drugs this is uh you know this
is things like uh cocaine and
amphetamine it's high levels of dopamine
with no effort okay they had to buy it
they had to find it they did whatever it
but that's no there's no physical effort
or mental effort involved in getting the
dopamine peak this is why hard work
followed by reward great working hard on
a relationship and then it gets better
there's a breakthrough or whatever it is
that is powerfully positive
dopamine that just arrives because you
say oh you're here so you get reward
terrible this is why rewarding every
little positive thing that a child does
with
you know their favorite thing eventually
diminishes the value of that thing and
diminishes their ability to get
motivated on their own it's a very very
powerful system one has to be very very
careful how one leverages it what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you